NATHAN FIELDER:
I've been told my personality
can make people uncomfortable.
Hey!
-How to Make Love All Night.
-Ah, well, you know...
I think we're gonna get along
pretty well.
(CHUCKLING)
FIELDER: But I've learned that
if you plan for every variable,
a happy outcome doesn't have
to be left to chance.
This conversation's
going pretty well.
Yes...
So, that's no accident.
Everything that's happened
today...
-(DOORBELL RINGS)
-(CHUCKLES)
-...I've rehearsed it...
-Hey! Hi! Nathan.
...dozens of times...
-Oh.
-Uh...
FIELDER:
...in a replica of your home.
This is what we can do for...
you, you, and you.
You know, just off the top
of my head,
I would say sure,
let's go with it.
This is gonna fun.
It will be.
FIELDER: My goal is for your
rehearsal to reflect reality.
The government
has Sasquatch liaisons.
-(CHICKEN SQUAWKS)
-(YELLS)
I love you, Daddy!
With this show, if
your performance isn't accurate,
you could ruin someone's life.
This is all sort of absurd.
-(CRIES)
-Keep him crying. Don't let up.
-Okay.
-I've got to tell you something.
I don't want
to talk to you again.
SPEAKER: Do you find
it's been healthy for you here?
N...
FIELDER:
Are you sure you wanna do this?
I don't really like
lying to people.
You're a liar!
Yeah, neither do I.
(BABY CRYING)
You're Willy Wonka,
and I'm Charlie Bucket.
I'm the bad guy in this?
-Well, but he's a dream maker.
-FIELDER: Okay.
And you're making
some dreams happen.
But kids died
in the factory?
Well, they supposedly died.
I'll read the book again
just to look into it.